qu'est ce qui vous prend de vouloir
quitter alors l'assemblée nationale
après seulement cinq ans demande à ses
cours en fait je me rappelle très bien
de en 2008 d'une interview dans le
journal le même public dans laquelle je
disais nous ne sommes que des passants
dès 2008 et je disais que j'ai plus ou
moins longtemps
oui mais que je souhaitais je pensais
déjà même la 1er fois que j'ai été élu
que pour moi la politique ne peut pas
être un métier au sens où ça doit rester
un engagement en fin de compte et que
plus on y reste longtemps plus on
s'inscrit en fin de compte dans une
forme je n'allais pas dire de confort
mais quelque part il faut savoir aussi
se remettre en cause et pour moi en fait
mon métier à la base ces conseillers en
formation et que j'ai pas envie j'ai 38
ans j'ai envie aussi de retourner à la
vie professionnelle de voir d'autres
choses de pouvoir aussi me ressourcer
sur le plan des idées sur et donc de
retrouver
voilà à la fois mes engagements
professionnels de nouveaux engagements
associatifs sans pour autant m'éloigner
de la chose publique parce qu'en fait
pour moi je suis un homme engagé dans
toute ma vie je serai en gagner